hey folks i thought i'd record a little
bit of housekeeping just because this is
an interesting place this is the last
unplugged show that we've recorded in
what is basically season two of mlst
we still have six shows that we have
filmed in the last six months or so that
we're building intros for so they'll be
coming but we're probably gonna pivot
away from this kind of um skype
conversation style content
um i mean to be honest we've done really
well i think we know how to polish a
skype conversation
and up the production values more than
most other podcasts but i do kind of get
the feeling that it's quite cheap and
easy to make this content and we're kind
of
not really you know we're strangling our
created potential a little bit there are
so many cool things going on in the ai
space at the moment and we've got such a
backlog that we can't comment on things
and we can't make kind of creative
content about things so you know in the
future we will still interview people
but it'll probably be this kind of
netflix pedagogical style content first
anyway and so that's it from me expect
six amazing shows that still need to be
released from this season
and then we'll see where we go from
there
cheers is there
like
um gardening happening in the background
landscaping
i heard a leaf blower maybe oh that
might have been my fan
oh okay so that was not a leaf blower
that is a fan
i mean we're not used to getting any
warm temperature over here so anything
over 20 degrees centigrade yeah and i
don't know what centigrade means so
it's probably not even nowhere let's
have a look what is 20
degrees
36 so that would be
70 68 yeah 68
is that hot
i don't know i live in san diego
yeah for probably for you it's not it's
not very hot yeah well
welcome to street talk today we have
batarli chile vitali is known as spicy
chili on yannick's discord yeah that's
right sometimes cool stuff happens not
on our discord on the alex discord but
we'll have to allow for that but vitale
is a machine learning research engineer
at cerebrus and we'll get into what
cerebrus does in in a little while and
um yeah i mean basically vitali welcome
to mlst and and tell us about yourself
and how did you end up here today
uh yeah so i
i went to ucsd and i now live in san
diego um
i got my degree in intelligent systems
robotics and controls and the
intelligent systems part is uh what the
ece department called
uh like our ai
courses were in there um upon graduating
i joined cerebrus that was almost uh
maybe three and a half almost four years
ago and
what cerebrus does it it's amazing and
the
you know the idea that they pitched when
i started was
it shocked enough that you know i wanted
to join and i wanted to be a part of
that um
three years later four almost uh i'm
still there haven't left uh often get
asked why i stay so long and
fundamentally it's because the idea is
so crazy that i want to see where it
goes
yeah
yeah i i gotta i gotta agree with that
so when i was when i was you know
preparing for the show reading materials
from uh
service and let me give you my layman's
understanding and then you can correct
it what's wrong here but
what really was was shocking about
it seems as if service is taking the
entire
motherboard that you might have in a
computer you know cpu memory routing
everything shrunk it down into you know
just a set of transistors only that are
sitting there on
on a wafer and then builds an entire
wafer with all these
all these things right so it's producing
this wafer scale as you call it you know
um
super computer really and what blew me
away by it there was some references to
um you know a single one of these
cerebus
wait for scale chips like the cs1 being
200 times faster
than a certain supercomputer which has
84 000
cpus okay and then and they said it's
200 times faster but that seems to
almost underestimate the achievement
here because
84 000 cpus if i'm doing the math
roughly right is about a thousand times
that's a thousand wafers okay that's a
thousand wafers of silicon to get 84 000
cpus i think
uh and you're 200 times faster than that
which is what's really per silicon on a
per silicon basis it's hundreds of
thousands of times
faster is that correct or am i wrong
um that that is correct um i think the
thing that you need to uh
kind of step back and think about when
designing a system is
what is it gonna be good for and what
won't it be good for um for instance
you know
even though gpus exist and they're much
faster than cpus at certain workloads
the majority of
things don't run on gpus whether they
don't need that much compute power or
they'll
or some workloads are just not that they
are maybe
not as compute bound but maybe more
memory bound um i think the workload or
the paper that you're referencing um
there is you know a class of algorithms
that all rely under the hood under um
yeah we're under the hood you're
effectively solving a pde
um and pd's uh in pde solvers end up
being very bandwidth bound um and so
yeah in that workload um
we have a system with a bunch of little
cores which can all communicate to each
other and
the communication latency and bandwidth
between the cores is massively high
and so when you have a problem that maps
well to that kind of setting um then
that's where cerebrus has massive winds
um
and so in effect what you're really
looking for are problems that
are extremely maybe parallelizable um
for lack of a better better term um and
when you have problems that are
extremely paralyzable um then you can
you know throw massive wafers or massive
amounts of compute at them
besides the pde solver
being one of those problems uh the other
big problem that we really target is uh
is deep learning
and
that deep learning is again one of those
problems that ends up being massively
quote unquote parallelizable
um and people throw mass massive amounts
of gpus at the problem and they'll
um
and they're in the
people
interconnect large amounts of gpus um in
order to solve deep learning problems
and instead of interconnecting massive
amounts of gpus and having all the
latencies associated with uh going off
of a chip to a different ship um
cerebrus instead just makes a massive
chip um
yeah and that's like
the
i don't know the secret sauce for how we
scale up uh going forward effectively
can you help me with the taxonomy here
because i know apple for example they've
just released the m1 and the m2 chips
and they're a system on the chips they
have many different types of system on a
chip but with cerebrus is it just lots
of cores on the chip or is it more than
that
uh it's
mostly lots of cores on a chip so it's
it's like a
general accelerator it's not really so
when keith said um
made a comment about the fact that we
shrunk down the cpu
as well as the accelerator part and the
memory and shoved it all in one chip uh
i feel like there's
a little disconnect there we still have
like um host processors
that
you know that will say okay now um
that'll effectively they end up serving
as effectively like ways in which we
ship data to and from the system uh when
it's needed okay um yeah
so what does the topology look like so i
mean again with the m1 chip that has
this concept of a unified memory but i
think it is shared so it's kind of
bucketed into different regions and then
different cores can access the memory
um yeah so i think that um i have
friends who work at other um silicon
companies uh
and one of them is like in a research
lab for um
fpga design and how that interacts and
in fpga he just calls it like a memory
with a little bit of compute uh thrown
in it's it's for moving data
and
something that he tries to push at his
company when i talk to him is the fact
that with this new wave of
hpc
computation
what matters isn't how many flops you
can throw at the problem what really
matters is how you move your data and
how you manage the data and where the
data is stored and all the memory
latency and bandwidth issues that come
up when training neural networks that is
what's going to win the game in the long
term um
and so like that's the game that we
effectively play differently than
what um nvidia has done
um nvidia has
you know their compute cores their their
tensor cores and then they have off-chip
memory
um
you know when you talk about the m1 chip
what or m2 chip from apple uh what they
did is they you know they have their cpu
gpu kind of all on one chip and then
they have memory that's very closely
integrated into that um
that kind of limits
how much memory they can have but it
also gives them much faster access to
that memory potentially uh
with cerebros what we did is we put the
memory
into the chip itself and so the the bulk
of the
memory that we use is in the chip itself
now this does come at the cost of
not being able to have as many flops
potentially because we like end up
reserving almost half the chip for
memory um
and it's about it's kind of funny like
if you want to think about it if you
reserve about half the chip for memory
then at most you're off by a factor of
two um
of how much like flaps you can have
versus how many flaps you should have
versus how much memory you should have
um but yeah so we reserve about half the
chip for memory
but
that means that we can get
really high utilization of our flops
and to kind of put that into perspective
uh if you take
um nvidia's numbers at face value for
how quickly they train
um something like resnet50
um and then you
you know
do the calculation
you can figure out what flop utilization
they are getting when training resnet
50.
and i think when i did that uh so when
the a100 first came out um
their kernels weren't completely
polished but they i did the math and i
think the a100 was getting something
like
16 percent flop utilization
for training resnet50 now imagine like
this company releases a new chip tells
you to buy it
they advertise all these flop counts and
you're like wow this is amazing and then
you can't actually use any of them
because of bandwidth and latency issues
uh now to be fair i think it's improved
since and i think they're in the low 20
flop utilization
but
on the v100 after years of improving
their kernels they got it up to i think
25 utilization and that's uh so that's
for resnet50 and that's like the network
that everyone hyper optimizes um and so
on the a100 they're probably not going
to get past
low 20s percent flap utilization
and so as these companies advertise
like these massive flop counts
what they
end up kind of hiding in the background
is like oh well you can't actually use
these slops for the standard workloads
that you kind of attack
um
and it's in the same and the story's
kind of the same because i think um one
of my
co-workers were saying that he took you
know hugging faces
um bert large
or bert base one of them uh
he ran it then tried to you know back
calculate the flap utilization and it
ends up being something like 17
and
you're just like okay thank you for all
these flops but can i actually use them
and that's where cerebrus um with our
you like with having
the majority or of our memory that's
like being used
on the chip itself with massive amounts
of bandwidth
uh we're aiming for creating kernels
with uh much better flap utilization um
now like i said you know
when the a100 came out for resin at 50
their flat utilization was like 16 then
it went up to like 20 something percent
i think currently
you know our flap utilization um
isn't at our target like 70 plus percent
flop utilization it's closer to like 40
for some of the like for bert base or
whatever else um but we are constantly
improving our our stack our kernels and
um our targets are in the you know 70 80
range
yeah
so for our listeners you can think of
the memory it's being kind of dithered
through you know spread evenly
throughout the entire you know the
entire wafer and i think that has some
some other trade-offs too i'm wondering
if you can hit on because
um so you know that case we talked about
earlier that fluid dynamics simulation
it wasn't just that it was
parallelizable but also it's a sparse
calculation you know if you think of
like finite element kind of mesh you
only depend really on your neighborhood
of um you know your your neighborhood of
cells and actually the mapping from that
problem map directly to the service chip
by kind of assigning those literal
finite element cells to you know units
um on the wafer and so if you're
commuting if you only need to
communicate with kind of nearby
neighbors
the cerebus chip has this sort of mesh
you know memory propagation where it can
propagate to the neighboring cells and
from there to neighboring cells
on the other hand if you have a dense
problem where you might need to go get
some values from a far away you know um
part of the wafer is there is there a
penalty for that is there like some type
of shortcut path where you can come back
out into like a different bus and then
route you know over there like how does
that kind of play out in the sparse
versus dense
um yeah
so our
so the memory layout and the fact that
you have you know your memory
distributed across the chip is a good
point um the chip is created to in a way
where you know each core has a piece of
memory next to it and
accessing that memory is
uh
is i think it's literally one clock
cycle um and then sending memory to like
the cores next to you that's also one
clock cycle um but then sending memory
across the entire chip
um
could end up being a lot longer
um now what is what is that relationship
like is it like what if it's two cells
away is that four o'clock cycles or how
does that work i think it's literally
two clock cycles uh i
wouldn't quote myself on that
i'm not a chrono writer they're they're
more keen on yeah just curious and how
quickly it propagates but um yeah so the
way that our ch our cores are designed
is that they are um
what i like to call maybe like a
coarse-grained uh programmable array or
yeah like
when you think of like fpgas you
literally program like
the
the
transistor at the transistor level
effectively
um
whereas for us you program at the core
level and then these cores you launch
some program on them and then they just
run and they're kind of independent on
of everything else the way that
computation or anything is triggered in
our cores is um using a data flow
architecture
effectively where
the core is
kind of in a wait state and compute is
triggered once
uh
this once data comes in through one of
the buses so there's i don't remember
how many buses effectively each core has
because it ends up changing with the
generations interesting it's like a
cellular automata almost right well
yeah
so yeah so when you talk about like
moving data um let's say that data comes
in on
one of the
i think our first generation had 24
buses so i'm gonna go with that uh it
comes in on one of the buses um
the core then knows like okay if i get
data from here i do this compute
alternatively if i get data from like
this bus then i end up shipping it
further
if i get data from here i you know do
this thing um and that's what triggers
computation is the arrival of data so
this is like a data flow architecture
which is different from like how gpus
work
which is really cool and it means that
like when data arrives on a bus it can
just then be shipped to the to the next
core and i think the hops are take
literally one um one clock cycle
um so like you know 10 hops away means
or 10 cores away means it's going to
take 10 o'clock cycles generally
speaking
when we program things or when we write
kernels
we try to minimize how much
data movement is needed for going like
to the other side of the wafer because
most times you don't need to go that far
necessarily
so it sounds like it's a decentralized
design because i had this conversation
all the time so whether it's your
organization source code data software
apparently even cpus there's this
dichotomy between centralized or
non-centralized and you said that
nvidia's architecture is very slow
on flop efficiency for this type of
workload
and so
if i understand correctly you've kind of
introduced memory efficiency to reclaim
the flops in efficiency and that works
particularly well for certain use cases
but are there any use cases where having
the centralized monolithic approach
would be faster
yeah so i okay if we're gonna give
nvidia their do um
what the nvidia
system can do really well is massive
matrix matrix multiplies
um
effectively like if you can prefetch a
bunch of stuff then the memory issues
could potentially go away and so like
when we talk about training
uh bert base i was saying they were
getting like
17 flop utilization but if you you know
create a wider version of bert uh and if
you get to like the size of gpt
um then you start pushing that 70 flop
utilization because you end up um
there's so when you when you train like
the 175 billion
uh parameter gpt3 you end up pushing
that 75 flap utilization um because you
could hide a lot of
uh latency issues
behind
a
thread concurrency and like uh running
like putting a thread to sleep running
or
cause it's waiting for memory and then
like uh
launching another thread um in the
foreground
on the core and so the core ends up
being always busy and in effect you the
wider the matrix multiply you do the
better
the flop count ends up being or the flap
utilization ends up being on gpus
um
so
something that you can say is that you
know when you scale
um neural network training
you
get better flop utilization on gpus um
the caveat there is then you also need
to interconnect massive amounts of gpus
in order to
to be able to scale and then the
inefficiency between transferring from
one gpu to another gpu could end up
being a headache and it's uh
in its own right
so there are there are trade-offs there
then uh
the other thing that you know um or the
other high-level way to look at this is
whenever you have a workload where
you are
not bandwidth bound um
then you're
okay to run on gpus
um
another way to say that is maybe like if
the arithmetic
arithmetic intensity of a workload so
like the amount of
fl flops you do per memory access
if that is high then
you're okay to run on gpus
well so i think there's another caveat
here too though that your ceo andrew
feldman i think talked about in an
interview which is that
yeah you can perform a matrix
multiplication very efficiently on a gpu
a massive matrix multiplication but
if it's a sparse matrix then you know if
if eighty percent of your entries are
zero
then you're performing a very fast but
useless you know kind of
bunch of computation there and yan
lacoon brings up that you know as neural
networks get larger and larger the
sparsity problem is going to be continue
to become worse at least for relu
you know networks so isn't there kind of
a fundamental trade-off there too
yeah so that is something that like um
we support as maybe a
first class one of our first class
design principles for our system was
supporting sparsity um and then that's
true um
if you
yeah as you get larger do we need that
much connectivity and how much of those
weights end up going to zero anyways
during the training process is is kind
of an open question um
with the sparse training there are
setups um
where it seems like
sparsity does provide for you
relatively large winds um and that's
what cerebrus wants to you know showcase
and um what cerebrus enables um yeah
okay because um you said before that in
a way it's like building a storm like
you said nvidia works really really well
when you've got these huge matrices to
multiply and memory but um neural
networks don't work like that like that
i don't think we should think of them as
monoliths
they are very very structured extremely
structured they have this weird um
property by the way we spoke to um uh
jonathan franco about this back in the
day but um you know they kind of like
starts off as a level playing field and
then very very quickly the structure
emerges and as you say you can throw
away almost all of the neurons in the
neural network and it doesn't make any
difference but if you do think of them
as being sparse then this very
decentralized approach in you know the
cerebros architecture it just seems to
follow naturally right
yeah um
i don't like if you think of them as
very sparse i don't know if the
decentralized approach is what matters
so much as
having an architecture that can support
sparsity now this decentralized approach
can support sparsity and we do um
but
there might be others that that do
support it so i don't want to write off
everyone who can support sparsity
because they're not taking this
decentralized approach um
the
the thing that sparsity fundamentally
requires
is
very
low latency
um high bandwidth memory
and that's why nvidia effectively has
issues with it um
in order for nvidia to get high flop
utilization like i said earlier what it
needs to do is you know launch a thread
um
tell that that thread will then try to
access its memory and
that thread will go to sleep while it's
accessing memory and the next thread
will be launched
the problem with that is when you
compile that kernel
you need to tell it what memory to
access
whereas
if your memory is
hot low latency high bandwidth then
you can tell
your
cores which memory to access at runtime
instead of needing to do it um
at compile time because like the the
prefetching
ends up like um
yeah
the other thing that nvidia kind of
has issue why nvidia will have issues
with sparsities because of their memory
access patterns when they access memory
um when i took you know gpu programming
courses uh years ago
the way that gpus access memory this was
like
pre-tensor chords even so it's even
worse now but the way that they access
memory is you tell it axis
give me this piece of memory and the gpu
ends up assuming that the next core is
going to ask for the next piece of
memory and the next four is going to ask
for the next piece of memory and so when
the gpu when you launch a kernel and you
say access this piece of memory
it
starts giving you 32 pieces of memory
um and as gpu generations have gone up i
think that 32 has gone up as well
pre-fetch
yeah it needs to pre-fetch memory
as a result if
all you need is one of
those elements
and you don't need the 32 because
sparsity you only need one or two of
those 32 elements
you just got a ton of elements shipped
to you
um
and you just consumed a massive amount
of bandwidth
when you already don't have a lot of
bandwidth uh per compute in gpus so i
think you i think you just taught me
something very interesting because i was
trying to wrap my head around why
cerebus would be good for you know
sparse calculation i kept falling back
to
old ways of doing sparse calculations
and most of those are all about
how can i take the sparse
thing and compact it you know like get
rid of the zeros and put all the stuff
that matters into
a smaller memory block and then
therefore i'm not
you know going to all these i don't have
to spam large amounts of memory that's
mostly zero and so and i think that was
all to do exactly what you were talking
about which is to evade
the difficulty of high latency
you know kind of kind of memory
architecture so if i'm understanding it
correctly the way cerebus
solves the sparsity problem is not by
compacting the memory really like
there's going to be lots of memory on
the cerebus wafer that's zero but it
just can get to the non-zero stuff very
quickly and it can decide where that
non-zero stuff is
at run time am i understanding correctly
kind of kind of no okay um so because we
have a data flow architecture like i
mentioned the compute is triggered once
the data comes to it
um the dataflow architecture effectively
um
means that as we propagate activations
through
the system
um
when an activation ends up arriving at
its correct core
then
the activation will end up accessing
some
some weight from the local memory
those will be multiplied and then
accumulation chain will happen along
like the multiple cores that you did the
that the tensors is split across
um
the way that like we originally
engineered it is that if inactivation is
zero
then you never have to propagate it at
all it just doesn't exist in memory nor
does it just exist at all
so i'm trying to understand that is this
is this quite similar to having the
concept of a lazily evaluated graph and
you're kind of traversing that graph
rather than monolithically computing
because the reason i want to get an
intuition is i know that the the
cerebrus chip has near linear speed up
in respect to sparsity and i'm thinking
well you've got a distributed
architecture i mean i appreciate even in
monolithic memory it's still scattered
all over the place so there are access
patterns and so on but now you need to
move it all around all of these
different memory stores all over the
place um is there not a cost associated
with that
uh there is and
so yeah like you said it's nearly linear
scale up with sparsity but it's not
linear um one of the issues that you end
up having is uh
how do you
at runtime like let's say that you
eventually the neural network
um
learns to love
a set of neurons for all samples and
therefore all like that part of the
neural network on that part of the wafer
ends up being dense and therefore the
compute is always on there and on a
different part of the network
it learns to you know have it off most
of the time
and the the question becomes can you
load balance um
training effectively like can you
during
runtime effectively redistribute
that kernel such that it ends up
consuming the
the cores spatially um equally um it's a
you know it's kind of well you end up
doing it with heuristics and sometimes
you can't always do it sometimes you can
um
and then
also i feel like we've we kind of ended
up talking a little bit more about or i
ended up talking a little bit more about
um activation sparsity um
but there's also the like concept of
weight sparsity which is what
most people end up researching um
in the field and with waste varsity um
i think that there are
there's a lot of nuance in how like
things run on our system
and
the way that you end up compiling ends
up kind of dictating what you're
targeting uh what kind of sparsity you
can target as well um because at the end
of the day um you have let's say a
matrix matrix multiply
there are
there's maybe like one
fpga
compiled multiplier
where both
the activation matrix and the weight
matrix can be sparse it's kind of like a
prototype that like people are playing
around with
but in general you get to
either have the activations be sparse or
the weights speed sparse
if you look at nvidia's like
inference sparsity
it's their weights that are sparse not
their activations
in our system
depending on how you compile you can
have either the weights be sparse or the
activations be sparse
yeah why can't you have both at the same
time and just for the benefit of our
audience as well can you just briefly i
know you did a little bit but just a
little bit in a bit more detail the
difference between weight sparsity and
activation [ __ ]
uh yeah so activation sparsity ends up
you know existing in neural networks um
very naturally because uh let's say you
do your
convolution then you apply a relu and in
general about half of your activations
are automatically zeros
um
on the weight sparsity side um you know
let's say you you have a matrix you
start training it and some of the
weights go to zero and those are you
know those are two different sparsities
where either your activations
are sparse in one setting and your
weights are sparse on the other side
uh
when you have
hardware that can support sparsity in
general um
it is
one of those matrices that ends up being
sparse and like i said in
in nvidia's a100 and now h100 um they
support
weight sparsity only
within sparsity within a block and
that's how they get a that's how they um
get away with or do their load balancing
is um the sparsity ends up being in a
single block and if you have that kind
of structured sparsity
then you kind of know that
all your cores are end up gonna end up
doing like fifty percent of the work
um some version of that uh
and
for our system
we
also support
only one of the matrices
being sparse um because i said like no
one has really cracked
having both weight and activation
sparsity um especially for training for
inference maybe somebody will do it
pretty soon like i said there's a
fpga
prototype that people are
you know playing around with but for
training it ends up like the network
ends up being a lot more dynamic and the
load balancing ends up being a lot more
dynamic and as a result
you kind of need to stick to one solve
that problem maybe sometime in the
future people will have be able to
support both matrices being sparse but
that's not the reality that we live in
now
and so
when on our system before you run the
neural network you kind of have to
choose do i want to focus on weight
sparsity or do i want to focus on
activation sparsity
i think
the majority of the research in the
field focuses on weight sparsity and so
that's kind of
the one that we're probably going to
design kernels for better in the long
term but we'll see well let me let me
ask you
why that is the case because
you know the weight sparsity at least in
so many architectures
uh isn't it you know doesn't naturally
happen like they naturally end up with
you know dense weights because it's very
rare for the optimizer to force
something identically to zero and maybe
make it really small or whatever
whereas activation sparsity for anyone
who uses relu or any other kind of
well not any other but any piecewise
linear thing that has a zero region you
know can end up with um
with that so why is the focus
on weight sparsity and not activation
sparse and by the way ditto the human
brain right which is
it has activation sparsity not so much
weight sparsity
uh okay so i first i don't like
comparing to the human brain oh that's
just me personally i don't try to do
that
i don't know if you guys love it or not
you guys i mean some people do it
i love it personally i stay away
um
secondly uh
so most
when you use relu uh
you get sparsity automatically and
a lot of neural networks were built with
relu but if you look at all the modern
neural networks most of them
target something like swish
uh
or jlu
um and yes there are zero regions in
those but it is relatively uncommon to
have identically zero um
activations or it's they're a lot less
common to have zero activations
with waste varsity you're also right it
like
uh naturally
sgd isn't gonna push you towards
zero automatically
but there are
um
tricks that people play that
if a weight is so there's like a
algorithm such as wriggle for instance
where if a cl if a weight is close to
zero you just set it to zero um and you
keep training the neural network and you
know you check once in a while and
if the
gradient of that weight is or that zero
weight is very high then you know that
that weight doesn't want to be zero
anymore so you turn it back on
yeah so there are
algorithms like that where you can
you know tell the training setup okay
we're gonna use sparsity in the weights
and uh
and we're gonna train sparse um yeah
that's kind of
one that we do i think i think we should
get back to wriggle in a minute because
that's a really cool algorithm from
google that allows you to kind of
iteratively specify the neural network
but um i mean to keep this point i don't
think it's necessarily zero which means
something is sparse i think like with
iterative magnitude pruning doesn't it
look at the um the gradient of the
weight basically so when when the when
it stops moving in the optimization
runtime then we think of it as being
dead and we prune it so it doesn't
necessarily have to be zero
i mean if you if you just prune a weight
even if so let's say it stops
moving
and it's let's say it's value is five
um
if it's within you know a matrix
multiply it's it's converged to five if
you
remove that weight
then you effectively apply a gradient
step that is pretty large
because you're gonna have zero
yeah because then you're applying
not because it's not a gradient but
you're applying a step in some random
direction that is nowhere related to the
gradient itself
okay
okay cool cool well um i mean one other
thing as well is that if you can't have
your cake and eat it and have sparsity
in um activations and weights doesn't it
defeat the purpose because the whole
point of this thing is to kind of
dramatically improve the memory
complexity of the network and if one of
those guys is still huge then
does that you know what's the cash value
of that
yeah so the the reason that like our
system can't support both necessarily at
the same time
um is because when i talked about the
activations being sparse um it was the
the sparse activations that we just did
not send through our dataflow
architecture when the weights are sparse
then it is the sparse weights that we do
not send through the dataflow
architecture um but
in the
you know um in the memory itself on the
chip
you
can still have like
so like
if
your weights are massively sparse
there's nothing that says that your
activation or this um this output
activation will be zero unless like an
entire row of the weight matrix is zeros
and if the entire row of the weight
matrix is zeros then just like get rid
of it and don't have that activation of
memory just have a narrower network
okay but i think if i understood you
correctly the the limitation like the
reason i choose between one of these two
things is i'm probably not going to say
this right but there's almost like a um
a routing that gets compiled into the
into the the mesh if you will the cpu
mesh ahead of time and
that routing and that sort of routing is
always going to take place so like in
other words if a packet enters the kind
of network it's always going to follow
like whatever route is compiled in there
and so therefore whatever is going to be
dense you can pile into that routing
and then whatever sparse ends up
happening at run time based on message
passing through that network is that
correct
yeah i think that's that sounds correct
okay
i'm sure that someone asked for reverse
is going to tell me that i said
something incorrectly in the next you
know week or something but at a high
level what's what's interesting is
you're right like this this cerebus
architecture is so nuanced and to me
it's just it's fascinating i can see why
you why you still work there and uh
just based off of what we've been
talking about what we've heard i'd
highly recommend other you know people
consider working there too
yeah yeah um
yeah i think like one of the things that
really
attracted me to it is you know um in the
very beginning
when
like we we kind of tell ourselves this
story um internally where
you know
back in the early 2000s late 90s
people ran neural networks on
cpus um and ran machine learning
algorithms and cpus and they were
relatively slow and
you know machine learning wasn't really
seen as a tool that could be used for
anything really exciting
yes you know machine learning had its
ups and downs but you know that was kind
of it it had its limitations because we
couldn't
run a lot of data through it and then in
2012
um
alex kraszowski uh
mapped a neural network to a gpu which
had way more compute um and
more bandwidth between the the the cores
than you would have if you like
interconnected a bunch of cpus
and as a result um ended up getting
about like a 20x speed up for training
neural networks and
his work
is a why we all know his name alex net
um and his b it effectively lit
the fire of like all of us looking at
like neural network training
um and what it can do
yeah um apologies to schmidt hooper if
he's listening
uh
um
but yeah like uh
the the proposition of cerebrus is that
we have a chip that is you know
something like 56 times larger
and
we can run neural networks you know the
alex net revolution happened when we
ran something that was 20 times faster
with the cerebrus chip when we run
things if they end up being um you know
20 to 50 times faster then you can run
on a
uh
on a gpu
where is that next revolution and what
can we unlock in the neural network
space that people haven't been able to
explore
easily or well on gpus
and you know what is going to be the
the neural network that we will all know
in the future what what is going to be
that cerebros net um that's kind of what
some of the
uh
some of the team at cerebrus is
exploring
yeah i mean i appreciate that you're
saying hardware can unlock a revolution
and potentially there are some
undiscovered phenomena that might exist
at the larger scales of neural networks
i mean i can get on board with that but
i mean why don't we just unpack the
sparsity thing a little bit more
so um
yeah where to start so most of the
specification algorithms are what i
would call you know kind of dense to
sparse algorithms which means you're
computationally bound by the size of the
bigger network so then it becomes a way
of efficiently you know productionizing
models for inference and they work
nearly as well but this is a
deliberately like ambiguous question why
do we need to start with the dense
version
why do we need to start with the dense
version
um
i don't think we do so there are two
schools of thoughts and like uh
something that we argue about on our
like internal research team sometimes um
there's the school of thought where you
should start dense and then go to sparse
uh there's the other one where you
should start sparse stay sparse there's
a third one where you should start
sparse go dense and then sparsify again
for inference um so there's a whole load
of ways that you could do it um the
argument for
starting dense then going sparse is the
explore exploit argument effectively
where
you
want to start dense because you want to
effectively be able to explore the
entire space
at the beginning
and then once your neural network has
settled into a regime where
it has found out that okay this subset
of weights is tending towards zero
zero amount and exploit the rest of the
structure
um that you know that's one camp
the other camp is a little more
empirical maybe um
you know you talk you can talk all you
want about the explore exploit paradigm
of training neural networks and you
should start you know dense
then prune and ghosts uh exploit the
spar structure but at the same time if
we just go full sparse right away
it doesn't look like we necessarily
lose a ton
the caveat there is you still have to
use an uh like a relatively smart
algorithm to um
to search
the entire space so you you still end up
needing to do the explore part and
that's kind of what um wriggle does or
helps you do is you can still explore
the entire weight space without
necessarily needing to do the dense
computation
one of the exploration algorithms
evolutionary algorithms like is there
any ability for cerebus to speed up ea
algorithms because if you want to start
sparse and stay sparse then the ea
algorithms at least give you some
exploration you know capability in an
arbitrary environment including a sparse
environment
yeah um something that's uh that we talk
about in
at cerebrus is like let the sparsity
algorithm
end up deciding the network
um or designing the network and so you
could talk about the
the using an ea algorithm
to design a neural network
alternatively you could just say
let let's just make a massive monolithic
network
and then run our sparsity algorithm in
the background and let that sparsity
algorithm end up
converging to
whatever structure
and so like yeah something that you know
has been stated is that like uh sparsity
is a
neural architecture search in itself in
a way
um but yeah look interesting the
ea algorithms to inform sparsity i don't
know if we've done that um
necessarily it's a good idea oh pretty
cool i did but but i mean a minute ago
you were kind of saying you know you
could start dense and sparsify or you
could start sparse and you could kind of
you know work from there um because it
feels like when when you've got this
highly dimensional perimeter space
starting sparse just it seemed it seems
like an impossibility a bit like the
curse of dimensionality i mean how the
hell could you possibly find anything
useful and um i read the the wriggle
paper when i was doing the intro for
jeff hawkins uh so i don't remember it
very well but i remember that i don't
know whether it's fair to say that it's
starting sebastian as i recall it was
kind of layer by layer it was like
densifying and sparsifying and then
re-densifying is it is something like
that is that a fair characterization
so it does start sparse the wriggle um
algorithm there are some that start
dense and do the specification but uh
wriggle in itself does start sparse um
what wriggle ends up doing is
effectively chooses a random sparsity um
it trains those weights for a set amount
of time and then you end up kind of
surveying all the weights and saying
okay which of these weights are tending
towards zero i'm going to get rid of
those weights
and then you look at all the those the
weights that are not active and you
uh and you end up saying okay which of
these weights have very high gradient
values and if they have very high
gradient values that kind of tells you
that they don't want to be zero they
want to move away from zero or at least
currently they want to move away from
zero so you reactivate those weights um
so that they can
you know keep looking uh and and this is
kind of how
wriggle even though you
start completely sparse um you can still
search the entire space of weights um
because
you end up
killing weights that are tending towards
zero and then you end up reviving the
weights that are interesting yeah
because i mean a neural network i mean i
use the uh terminology when we spoke to
franco it's like a block of clay and you
can chip away at it and you can create
any structure that will sing your tube
and presumably because of all of the
symmetries and all the various different
things that it can do that there are
almost uncountably many structures you
could find in that parameter space
and wriggle as i understand it does
robustly find great sets of weights for
a whole bunch of problems
um but yeah what's the intuition why is
it possible to start sparse and build up
well that's the thing like i
i personally like when we talk about
intuition i argued uh or i tend to argue
for the
uh
explore exploit route where you start
dense and then go sparse um
i don't have good because that's what my
intuition tells me to do
in the
like first stages of training you can do
a massive exploration if you start dense
and then go sparse and that was my
intuition always but at the same time
empirically um
it seems to work and i don't know if i
have a great intuition for it right now
but um like i said the wriggle algorithm
still does do effectively in explore
it's just a slightly longer explore
where it
its explore stages um you know
explore these this subset of weights
and then
you know revive new weights um
i think there was there is some research
where they look at how many weights end
up being touched on using the regular
algorithm for training and if you tune
it correctly then
the algorithm will end up
reviving all the weights at least uh
once or it's something like 95 percent
of the weights at least once during the
training setup so it still does
explore all the weights or touch upon
okay
so i mean a couple of places to go from
here i mean first of all a lot of these
inductive priors they are ways of
introducing parameter efficiency and in
theory if you have something like
wriggle you could just start with a huge
mlp and and you could do the same thing
you're doing with the cnns and the
transformers i mean um i guess like the
question is if regal does do what we you
know what it says it does then we should
be able to discover all of this
interesting phenomena at a higher scale
which would have taken a larger dense
network to discover and so far we
haven't found anything right
uh
nothing that i feel like translates to
like oh okay this looks exactly like a
convolution um if we start like from a
dense matrix a convolution is a linear
layer therefore it can be represented
within a you know a matrix and so like
theoretically if you started with a
dense matrix
and ran wriggle on it and input cv
images would it find a convolution uh i
don't know if i'd seen anyone show that
it has or could um
and
yeah that that's kind of like the thing
about neural networks is in the hidden
layer
after the first hidden layer or whatever
um at that point what is the neural
network representing
none of us know and so would it
represent a convolution or would it
converge to a convolution or would
wriggle like help that matrix converse
to a convolution it's uh it's hard to
say that it would
we don't know
yeah and i mean i think that's kind of
the crux of
you know the question that a lot of
people have in their mind is
going back to the dense to sparse versus
you know start sparse and stay sparse or
vice versa
is that if you look at the kinds of um
inductive priors that people come up
with uh that
that we put in that has dramatic effects
on performance right
um they're usually something sparse like
let me take this little three by three
thing and and just move it around i.e
everything else in the matrix is zero so
i had this you know or uh how about a
dropout layer like i'm just gonna throw
in something and just chop out entire
you know parts and like we always come
up with these sparse
sparsifications almost uh i mean there
are some exceptions like sure let's come
up with how about lasso the old school
you know um
sparsifying technique and linear you
know linear regression where i just add
a
a weight which is the absolute sum of
the the
you know slopes the betas or whatever
and it kind of magically forces a lot of
them to to zero you know so i mean we
just keep coming up with these ways to
add discreteness and sparsity um and
that's why i think there may be a lot of
doubt that uh starting dense and
that you're ever going to get to those
kind of sparse almost
like a computational program-like
um
things in the network
yeah like definitely like the
what the sparse city algorithms will
find is
is definitely an open question um i
think the
the biggest
issue that i see with that open question
is
even if they converge to something and
let's say i go through the look at the
weights of a neural network and i look
you know scour it and i find something
that looks like a convolution
and am i only finding that because i
want it to look like a convolution or is
it actually like doing something that is
like how much of that will
as we you know venture down that path of
research how much of that research will
end up being cherry-picked
is what i worry about um and so like
yeah i don't know how easy it will be to
say uh yes this is
this is a convolution or this looks like
what whatever you want to say right like
like the neural network may decide first
to uh fourier transform the inputs and
then just do a dense multiplication of
vectors because that's the equivalent of
convolution and
fourier space and then it inverts it
somewhere and like you have no idea so
yeah
and yeah and i don't i personally don't
think that we should start like down
that path because it'll end up being
cherry-picking but maybe some people
find it super interesting and maybe
they'll find something that's actually
cool well i think that's what kind of
the agi people
or folks that are very optimistic let's
say about the
um artificial intelligence capabilities
you know they would argue that right
which is why are you trying to
force on the neural network you know
convolution like that's such a human
type of calculation that we came up with
that fits in human math you know
artificially intelligent math may come
up with some really bizarre
you know computation that's so far
beyond human cognition and yet it works
just as well or maybe even much much
better because it does some really
bizarre yeah if we can anthropomorphize
lambda then we can absolutely
anthropomorphize our inductive prize
fair enough yeah i i think the
in my perspective the inductive priors
that we throw at neural networks we
throw at neural networks
because they
save resources and or well a they work
b
they work on the hardware that we have
um and so like
you know
gpus being a graphics processor they can
do convolutions um at least somewhat
well
and
as a result you know if we want to
process our neural network and we don't
want to store
massive weight matrices for dense matrix
well you know we don't have the
resources to store
weight matrices that large let's instead
store this little three by three thing
and then weight share it across the
entire image and okay look at all the
resources that we saved and that's kind
of i think what ends up happening for a
lot of the um
you know it's not
how we pitch it like oh i'm using this
convolution because it saves me
resources we say oh it's you know it
maps well to images so obviously it
should be used um but i think somewhere
in the back of everyone's head we kind
of need to acknowledge that it's
saving as resources um so that we can
run potentially and larger neural
networks and we can do more cool things
with them
um yeah there might be a cost though i
mean i think there's an interesting
continuum of how principled these
inducted prizes are and as you say you
can you can pitch it as they're saving
resources but um just uh i mean we're
doing a chomsky intro at the moment so
we're reading all about newton and how
he threw away this
you know like the early scientists had a
very mechanistic view of how the world
worked they thought the world was a
machine and then all of that went out
the window when he discovered his theory
of gravity and then um
from that point on most of science was
about creating models of reality and we
just kind of threw away any notion that
we could understand reality we called it
the ghost in the machine but i suppose
it's a similar thing with these inducted
priors now that to a certain extent
we're not really deleting ourselves that
we can you know really understand
computation and reality it's just
something which is a temporary expedient
yeah
um
yeah i personally i think i've mentioned
to to keith um
one of the things that i want to like
play around with at cerebrus is the
concept of
just
forget the inductive bias
throw a massive matrix
matrix multiplier massive matrix
multiplies at the problem and see if you
converge or can do as well on imagenet
as you could with resnet
or what amount of resources does it take
to do that well um and then i
the reason that i haven't really like
sued this too much is because i kind of
want to take it even a step further um
and instead of
doing it with matrix multiplies do it
with a full-on
dag
um so something that you know um
that i i noted earlier is gpus require
these matrix massive matrix matrix
multiplies in order to get good luck
utilization
our system is designed to get good flop
utilization from uh
from just vector
uh scalar multiplies
um
and so if you
have you know
a connectivity matrix
you can have you know the
the input as your
input neurons and then you can create
the next neuron using those and then you
can create the next neuron using
effectively that vector times a weight
matrix
right
and so you could just have
effectively like the next element
created as a vector vector multiply
with the weight matrix of all the
previous
um neurons
and so there's no concept of the layer
at all and
and then when you throw sparsity into
those uh
vector
vector matrix uh multiplies at that
point it begins to look like a pure dag
almost with or that connectivity matrix
begins to look like a pure dag um
and there's a
the the
when you look at that connectivity
matrix let's say if you
cut you know squares into it where
everything outside of those squares is
zero um then you end up getting like an
lp um
effectively and
like there's a team looking at um or
yeah one of the
pitches for an alternative compiler for
our system is just to have
one kernel and you let sparsity define
the the shape of the neural network and
so you don't actually have to write
multiple corner kernels for for anything
you just have sparsity define
the uh the structure um
and so like and you just write a kernel
that does like one
massive dag computation um
something that else that you can use
that for though is to run a massive dag
and give it no inductive bias and see
what it does
um and so they're they're playing around
with
or that that team is playing around with
like how how do we use this as a
compiler and they're writing a kernel
for it and i'm playing around with
um
effectively
hijacking some of their work and trying
to get a data loader you know
compiling with it to try to run a weird
dag uh
set up well hey crazy question for you
does it have to be acyclic like why on
your chip can i run
a possibly cyclic graph and just compute
for a period of time and see if it
stabilizes
you can uh
at that point though if you look at it
the connectivity matrix or connectivity
setup like the next neuron is created
using the previous neuron and even if
they are pointing to the same point in
memory um you're still creating a new
neuron effectively right well i'm
thinking about these kind of like like
we talked you know these self-repairing
cellular automata where it just kind of
sits there and keeps running this
calculation that's that's cyclic but of
course there's there is timing you know
but it just runs for a while and then if
it reaches some equilibrium maybe that's
the answer
yeah baby uh it's not something that i
was going to throw in at the beginning
but maybe
as the next step if it's needed i don't
know why have the inductive prior of uh
a cyclic you know
yeah
yeah
um final question before you go do you
think neural networks can be
characterized as locality sensitive
hashing tables
ah
um
so where didn't you guys do a uh
a podcast with a guy that had both
paper yeah
yeah um
so i feel like a lot of that
or that that entire conversation almost
was premised upon the fact that you're
using relu's
um or any piecewise linear activation
function yeah
does anyone still use things like that
or does everyone just use
you know
yeah but so this is this is a bit of
like and we've gone back and forth with
people in the comments on this too like
yeah yes the theory um in order for the
proof to be valid requires that it be a
piecewise linear function okay but on
the other hand do any of us really
legitimately believe that the little
bump or the tiny little curve thing or
something in the activation is where the
neural network is spending all its time
you know focusing on all its parameters
i don't think so like and i and i know
from practical experience that it's off
into the into the linear regions like 95
percent of the time
it's not it's not just that though i
think that the main idea as i understand
it is that neural networks are a
space partitioning scheme and doesn't
matter what activation function you use
the whole purpose of neural networks is
to like you know figure out these
interesting polytopes that surround your
training data
yeah but then you're just saying that uh
like a neural network ends up you know
seeing a vector in some space and then
it maps it to
an output class or whatever um yep
well it is a function at the end of the
day it's a it's a fun no no it's it's
it's more than that we're saying more
than that which is that that by their
nature what neural networks do is they
chop up they keep chopping they chop the
space they take a look if this area is
confused they chop it up some more if
it's still confused they chop it up some
more and it doesn't matter if these if
these cuts are
linear if they're sharp cuts or if they
have a little bit of like fuzziness a
little curvature to it that's not
changing what they're fundamentally
doing which is they're hierarchically
chopping up the space into progressively
finer and finer buckets
until the the nice little
linear affine transformation gets it all
correct like i think that's you know
that's really like a pretty important
insight which is that the way in which
neural networks are kind of solving the
hard problem of dealing with
non-linearity is not by finding some
like
nice smooth you know thing they're just
chop chop chop chop chop into higher and
higher resolution buckets until like
i've got enough resolution to fit
everything with with lines basically
with hyper planes
yeah
uh and i mean i feel like it's almost
impossible to disagree with that
statement like when you oh it's possible
you can look in our comments well for
sure
i know i i mean when i watched that
podcast uh
yeah like it high level made sense to me
my only like
issue with it was it seemed like the the
theory
was only like perfect with rey lews
and so like it became hard to say that
it like is
a theoretical result for all neural
networks but when you take a neural or
when you take a look at neural networks
as a whole um
it still seems to make sense because
like realistically i can represent most
non-linearities as a piece or
approximate most
or all non-linearities as piecewise
linear functions so
no that's so that's that's totally fair
i think for me it was just i don't know
you know maybe because i started a long
time ago like thinking about neural
networks because because i'm i'm getting
kind of old now but but uh
you know i used to i used to think
really before that process of preparing
for that interview that that little
smoothness that little bump you know the
little smooth areas of these activation
functions
were where the magic was happening and
and it shattered my kind of dreams there
and like now i realize it's really just
chopping things up
i mean i think that the the context of
that show was all about extrapolation
and an extrapolation is is a slippery
word so you know yamba [ __ ] meant it to
be um outside the convex hull of the
training data and
i think sean may would say in a very
general sense extrapolation is about you
know taking an additional piece of
information and converting it into a new
situation and experience space which is
far away from anything i've seen in
training and if you do have this idea
that you're just kind of decomposing the
euclidean space into these other
polytopes then it to my mind it throws
away the notion that they can possibly
extrapolate
yeah um
yeah i don't see a world in which we can
extrapolate easily with the paradigm
that we have um
yeah
oh well that was easy
amazing
anyway we should on that bombshell we
should wrap up the uh vitali chile thank
you so much for joining us today really
appreciate it yeah thank you for having
me
all right pleasure pleasure hope you
enjoyed that conversation um hit the
subscribe button because the next show
we're going to release will be with
professor noam chomsky
the most important intellectual of the
20th century
yeah you don't want to miss it
see you later